on va parler de la 25e édition du
Printemps des Poètes organisé par le
réseau des médiathèques et les écritures
contemporaines de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines l'événement
revient cette année avec au programme
des spectacles des ateliers des
rencontres des podcasts et des lectures
un programme très riche pour en parler
avec nous Catherine baron vous êtes
chargés de la programmation pour les
écritures contemporaines et Gilles
cheval vous êtes spécialiste en poésie
alors le thème de cette année vous nous
l'avez dit au tout début de cette
émission c'est frontière alors pourquoi
ce thème Catherine baron qu'est-ce qui
vous évoque alors déjà c'est en fait le
Printemps des Poètes est une opération
nationale donc c'est eux qui ont choisi
chaque année c'est une lettre de
l'alphabet voilà donc là c'était F
frontière après c'est vrai que c'est
d'actualité puisqu'on passe de plus en
plus
les frontières à tous les niveaux
pour le Printemps des Poètes à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines il s'agit
surtout de passer au-delà des frontières
vers l'ouverture la découverte de
l'autre d'autres poésies puisqu'on a une
franco-tunisienne
Gilles pourra mieux en parler pour le 11
mars
Ryan qui interviendra donc le 11 mars à
la médiathèque du canal et qui est donc
effectivement Franco tunisienne et c'est
amusant on parle de frontières
géographique mais il n'y a pas que ça
c'est à dire que je suis assez quand
même étonné c'est un peu une constante
finalement auprès des poètes ils n'ont
pas tellement de frontières pas
tellement de limite c'était verte voilà
Nawel benkrayem et poète elle est
musicienne à des chanteuses à des
comédiennes et beaucoup des intervenants
de cette année du Printemps des poètes
sont comme elle il y a un metteur en
scène également qui interviendra qui est
poète également
enfin voilà c'est quelque chose qui est
assez impressionnant et
voilà ça se vérifie chaque année mais je
trouve que cette année alors je sais pas
si tu as fait exprès mais quand même là
c'est bien trouvé
alors on va tout de suite préciser par
rapport au programme
nawell en fait est bloqué par les
transports et la elle enchaîne les
concerts en ce moment à Toulouse et du
coup samedi la rencontre qui était
prévue à la médiathèque non à la
librairie du pavé du canal
sera en fait non pas 15 heures mais à
l'issue de son concert dont il va parler
la lecture concert a lieu à 17h à la
médiathèque du canal et la rencontre qui
devait avoir lieu à l'origine à la
librairie bas se fera à la médiathèque
dans la foulée de la lecture concerne il
est libraire sera présent le pavé du
canal parce que c'est important de
parler des libraires de proximité il
sera présent également sur d'autres
d'autres moments du Printemps des poètes
qui se déroule jusqu'au 25 mars inclus
et d'ailleurs le 25 mars Gilles vous
allez animer deux rencontres oui je vais
animer une rencontre avec Cécile oumani
qui est également Franco tunisienne
parce que décidément les frontières
et britanniques voilà oui une rencontre
avec Cécile ou Mannick qui a déjà publié
des dizaines de livres ça fait 25 ans
qu'elle publie et là on parlera de son
nouveau livre avec
c'est la petite cerise sur le gâteau un
peu de musique avec Louis Catala
violoncelliste et ça se passe donc à la
médiathèque des Clayes-sous-Bois le 25 à
17h30 18h30 je ne sais plus en même
temps
parce qu'il faut que je vienne quand
même
de rencontres et une programmation
tellement riche que on se perd il y a
aussi des spectacles de chant qui sont
au programme alors comment est-ce qu'on
lit en fait au final la poésie avec le
chant
alors déjà les poètes ont toujours
travaillé avec tous les artistes
mélanges souvent en transversalité
là par exemple pour Frida Kahlo et les
poètes il y aura donc trois musiciens de
jazz qui vont à la fois interpréter des
musiques en lien avec le Mexique avec
Frida Kahlo et puis il y aura des
lectures de textes de Paul Eluard
d'Aragon
également de Frida Kahlo puisqu'elle a
écrit des poèmes notamment dans ces
lettres d'amour à Diego
voilà donc ça se marie très très bien
également
pour Nawel el tira certains de ses
poèmes tout en chantant également
voilà qui est aussi
compositeur qui travaillent énormément
avec des musiciens là il n'y aura pas de
musiciens mais la partition qu'il va
jouer avec Frédéric Bruyas ça sera très
musical
et je tiens à souligner d'ailleurs que
c'est une création exprès pour notre
Printemps des Poètes à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines de même que le
Frida Kahlo le 18 mars à plaisir au
théâtre Robert Manuel
en partenariat avec la ville
ça vous évoque quoi vous la poésie
Grégory canalet Gabriel goncier sur la
thématique
ces frontières sont pas infranchissables
grâce aux mots on va pouvoir aller
au-delà de ces frontières et frontières
géographiques des frontières de l'esprit
on va pouvoir aller au-delà avec la
poésie moi la question que j'avais envie
de vous poser c'est pourquoi c'est un
événement justement qui revient chaque
année et pourquoi c'est un événement
important pourquoi il faut défendre la
poésie lors de cet événement selon vous
alors parce que la poésie n'est pas très
du moins la poésie actuelle
contemporaine n'est pas très présente en
librairie ou un radio ou à la télévision
donc alors que les poètes créent
énormément et s'agit encore une fois
pour beaucoup mieux en parler avec moi
les maisons de d'édition font un travail
absolument remarquable je te laisse
poursuivre et en vérité les poètes sont
partout mais on les voit très peu c'est
une scène entre guillemets une scène
très peu médiatisée c'est un petit peu
comme la chanson française à l'heure
actuelle il y a des festivals qui lui
sont consacrés il y a un public très
fidèle mais ce n'est pas médiatisé on
n'entend pas parler de beaucoup de
chanteurs français à l'heure actuelle et
pour les poètes c'est un peu la même
chose alors qu'en fait ils sont
absolument essentiels et ils
interviennent partout c'est-à-dire qu'on
a toujours cette image un petit peu
caricaturale du poète et de la poésie
complètement déconnecté de la réalité
enfermé dans son monde alors que c'est
tout l'inverse les poètes ne sont pas
juste là pour écrire des poèmes ils sont
là pour transmettre leur d'ateliers
l'écriture ils vont partout dans des
écoles ils font énormément de rencontres
ils montent sur scène donc là il touche
encore à autre chose on en parlait tout
à l'heure il touche à la musique à la
performance enfin oui c'est important de
les mettre en avant vraiment parce que
c'est une scène absolument passionnante
il y en a vraiment pour tous les goûts
et contrairement à ce qu'on imagine
c'est extrêmement accessible voilà il
suffit de se laisser porter c'est la
musique des mots donc si on aime la
musique on est obligé d'aimer la poésie
peut-être pas toute la poésie mais au
moins certaines choses
justement vous pensez qu'il y a un enjeu
à mettre en avant la poésie notamment
pour les nouvelles générations les plus
jeunes pour qui ça peut-être tendance à
se perdre un petit peu cette pratique de
des œuvres poétiques alors je dirais on
n'est pas obligé de lire de la poésie
quand on est enfant même si dans
l'absolu c'est quand même dommage de
s'en priver mais
de toute façon on en retrouve dans les
livres pour enfants il y a pas besoin de
chercher très très loin à toutes les
pages j'ai envie de vous dire voilà
c'est très accessible et la pratique de
la poésie fait énormément de bien aux
enfants j'ai eu l'occasion de le de le
constater à plusieurs reprises c'est
assez impressionnant de voir à quel
point ça peut débloquer des enfants sur
l'écriture voilà d'un point de vue
purement pragmatique clairement c'est
une forme qui laisse énormément de
liberté qui laisse beaucoup de place à
l'imaginaire et pour des enfants c'est
c'est magnifique et généralement les
derniers de la classe sont les meilleurs
jeux et c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que
cette année pour le Printemps des Poètes
à Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines on fait un
focus
sur une revue de poésie junior qui a été
créée par le Centre de Création jeunesse
de Tinqueux qui a un centre magnifique
près de Reims
matteiya bisniaque qui le dirige et la
crée d'ailleurs un festival de poésie
jeunesse qui est le seul en France et
donc Gustave junior cette revue c'est un
quatre pages en numérique qui met en
valeur des poètes actuelles qui écrivent
pas seulement pour les enfants
et donc les médiathèques vont faire un
focus sur cette revue en
mettant en exposant des poèmes de
dominique Sampiero de carnora de Pierre
Soletti donc voilà là les enfants
pour en trouver
matière à découvrir et on a une création
justement autour de cette revue par une
poète Laura luthar qui est également
comédienne le 15 mars à la médiathèque
Anatole France appartient de cette revue
peuvent faire une lecture
Gustave
alors c'est une surprise c'est en
création donc je peux pas en dire plus
venez
j'ai le cheval d'avoir répondu à nos
questions alors pour rappel le Printemps
des Poètes c'est du 10 au 25 mars à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines vous
retrouverez toute la programmation sur
le site internet des médiathèques de
saint-quentin-en-yvel